[Musique]
l'intelligence artificielle s'avère être
un outil de plus en plus utile cette
technologie révolutionnaire est des
humains atteindre un niveau d'efficacité
étonnant un exemple la sécurité
ferroviaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
inaccessible
isolé
le paysage est grandiose
seul le bruit du convoi trop de la
quiétude des lieux
durant son trajet le train traverse des
ponts et franchit des tunnels mais
surtout une négocié des courbes serrées
[Musique]
le fait que notre mènera soit construite
50% de courbes ses clacs a un impact
parce que le rail se comportent de façon
différente donc le rail va en tendance à
miser davantage sur nos courbes à haut
degré
unique voie reliant port cartier à
fermont s'étire sur 412 km ces trains y
circulent quotidiennement les
locomotives remorque jusqu'à 220 wagon
au fil des saisons le rail se
contractent et se dit l'acte le métal se
fatiguent les prix peuvent survenir
rapidement et c'est ça qu'il faut éviter
transports canada est clair
arcelormittal doit mener une inspection
de son chemin de fer deux fois par
semaine nos inspecteurs vont être à la
recherche de défauts potentiels qui
pourraient causer débris ou qui
pourraient causer des ralentissements
sur la moselle
et voit à noter par exemple les taudis
traverse l'état du valasse l'état des
différentes composantes des rails le qui
permettent de fixer les rails donc tout
ça va être notre et evra est ensuite
envoyé une base de données qui va nous
permettre ensuite le biais d'un cocotier
malgré l'oeil attentif des inspecteurs
impossible de détecter toutes les
failles ici la solution se trouvait du
côté de l'intelligence artificielle
imaginons des algorithmes capables de
détecter l'usure du chemin de fer avant
même qu'elle ne soit perceptible
c'est le défi que se sont lancé m
metrics spécialiste en inspection
d'infrastructures de transport avec la
collaboration de luc faucher d'avoir
recours à l'intelligence artificielle
avec une aussi bonne technologie permet
vraiment d'inspecter beaucoup beaucoup
de paramètres d'une voie ferrée serait
pas possible à un humain et en marchant
ou en faisant justement par une routine
avec un camion il ya trop d'informations
c'est impossible de voir tout ça
plus que l'intégration d'une technologie
comme celle ci peut nous permettre c'est
vraiment de capter ce que l'allemagne
pourrait échapper
[Musique]
voici le camion d'inspection un véhicule
high tech à l'arrière deux capteurs
chacun se compose d'une caméra haute
définition et d'un laser
le système qui est là est relié à des
serveurs à l'intérieur de la boîte du
camion qui sont ici à l'intérieur du
coffre metter donc on ait un premier
savoir ici c'est vraiment l'acquisition
des données donc tout ce qui est pris au
sol vont être enregistrées intérêts du
québec sont ici à savoir la
un système de suspension et de
compensation terme est la captation
d'imagés nettes malgré les soubresauts
du véhicule
sur le toit ya vraiment deux antennes
qui vont justement interrogé que cette
étude pour savoir la position là
coordonnées gps du système ce qui nous
permet pour chacune des images de savoir
où est ce que l'image a été prise c'est
beaucoup plus sympa ensuite lorsqu'on
veut donner les résultats on sait
exactement à quel endroit et est située
la composante le regarder
[Musique]
aujourd'hui luc faucher part à la
recherche de défauts et visible
[Musique]
le long du parcours les lasers balaie la
structure du rail qui mesure trois
mètres et demi de larges sommes
même si le camion roule à 40 kilomètres
à l'heure les caméras ultra rapide
photographie la voie ferrée millimètre
par millimètre
dans le système réussi à prendre une
image vraiment complète en trois
dimensions du rail et diamants de ses
composantes
un des paramètres importants pour
arcelormittal entre autres ce sont les
éclisses qui sont fixés au bout de
chaque rail pour vraiment s'assurer que
deux fins de rails que c'est vraiment un
vis-à-vis pour que le train puisse
circuler de la bonne façon donc l état
de santé de ses écrits si on veut
s'assurer bien entendu sont capables de
faire leurs fonctions c'est aussi la
qualité des traverses en bois donc
s'assurer que la traverse est capable de
continuer son support de toute la
structure qui est sur le dessus et le
poids également des wagons lucky qui
repose sur le rail
inspecter le rail génère 412 millions de
photos à haute résolution si on compte
les voies d'évitement on ajoute 50
millions de photos donc en volant 40 km
on obtient sur des longs parcours des
millions et des millions d'image si bien
que les humains ne serait pas en mesure
d'interpréter autant d'image apparaît
beaucoup trop de temps c'est pour ça que
les algorithmes et et jean sortie ça va
nous aider ici a vraiment bien définir
les composantes du rail et à sortir
toutes les informations nécessaires pour
nos analyses on voit ici l'image de kate
en trois dimensions puis sur l'image on
voit très bien si les traverses de bois
par exemple donc les algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle on voit ici
que les traverses de bois sont très bien
défini un autre exemple qu'on peut voir
ce sont les crampons qui vient de fixer
les règles dans les travers qui sont
également entourées plomb que le système
leur permet de voir en plusieurs
composantes
une fois le relever terminée les données
sont transférées au centre d'expertisé
ferroviaire rail
les serveurs qui hébergent
l'intelligence artificielle amorce alors
leur analyse
chaque pièce chaque composante du chemin
de fer est mémorisé
l'intelligence artificielle recherche et
interprète les indices d'usure et de
défaillance sur chacune des photos
[Musique]
c'est ce qu' il ya tellement d'image qui
sont prises j'ai tellement
d'informations qui sont tirés que ça
prend des savoirs très puissant pour
sortir l'information safran jusqu'à
trois jours de justicier l'information à
partir de deux serveurs de très haute
puissance on aimerait avoir des
informations en temps réel mais pour le
moment où on se parle on est capable de
prendre les images les traités dans les
trois-quatre jours et donner les
résultats ensuite à la compagnie une
fois l'analyse complète et arcelormittal
reçoit un rapport sous forme de tableaux
d'or
lorsque les résultats nous sont
présentés on peut voir clairement pas
positionnement gps à quel endroit sur la
voie ferrée on observe un défaut dans le
rail donc ça va nous permettre
d'intervenir de façon ciblée à l'endroit
où on observait une défaillance
ça nous permet de bien prévoir la durée
de vie de nos composantes et
d'intervenir à temps pour les remplacer
à coke beuvron et aussi
notre niveau de sécurité et fiabilité ce
match prenne fin
[Musique]
encore jeune l'intelligence artificielle
comme outil d'inspection n'a pas déployé
son plein potentiel
plus fauchés aide à peaufiner les
algorithmes il se déplace là où
l'intelligence artificielle suspecte une
anomalie comment voyez
ici le joint il est très sympa vraiment
vraiment faible donc comme il fait plus
autour de 15 degrés dehors
de la détention qui vont se rajouter
dans ce coin l'objectif c'est à chaque
fois qu'on fait un relevé on regarde où
justement eu des erreurs puis on essaie
de pallier à ces erreurs là en ajoutant
des modules d'apprentissage pour que le
système soit de plus en plus performant
et donc vraiment le bon résultat
recherché
à ce jour le taux d'efficacité de
l'intelligence artificielle dépasse 80
18% d'ici peu elle devrait être sans
faille à ce moment il y à fort à parier
que le système de caméra couplé à
l'intelligence artificielle puisse
parcourir d'autres réseaux
c'est un peu un banc de test on est ici
non qu'on a accès à un inventaire qui
est géant qu'est gigantesque on pourrait
pour recréer en laboratoire et avec
arcelormittal profite vraiment tous les
algorithmes tous les traitements mais
notre objectif c'est ça c'est que le
team en cette technologie là soient
déployés partout au québec au canada en
amérique du nord même dans le monde
[Musique]